To focus on gut healing is the best to put green smoothies aside and instead eat cooked
fruits and vegetables. If so, and if I were to heat up my greens smoothie like a soup is that
adequate. So, if you're trying to heal your gut, let's say your cancer is pretty much stable,
but my gut is the worst thing going and I just have never been able to heal it. We have always
recommended I don't know if anybody's, I don't know if this is a real big thing anymore but years
and years ago it was an insane and it was what's called the GAPS diet, G A P S and it was a gut healing
diet and you started off in different phases of this GAPS diet and really we used to take
people through these phases and it depended upon how bad they were depending on what phase we'd
started. So, if they were just super autoimmune and did not have cancer then we would start off
in the phase one GAPS diet where we do just bone broth. That's all they would eat as bone broth for
multiple days depending on their condition. Everybody was different. We didn't have just a set
protocol we dealt with everybody individually but bone broth is got nutrition in it and people would
we teach people how to make their own bone broth and it has a lot of glutamate in it. That's why it can
be very healing to the gut. Well, we don't do that with cancer patients because glutamate is very
healing to the gut because it stimulates growth and it can be very growth, grow growth of cancers.
So, we certainly don't want that. So, we would skip that phase if you have a diagnosis of cancer.
Probably even if you are in complete remission. Well, if you're in complete remission,
your cancer is no evidence of disease that maybe you could do a few days of that.
But let's say you're not. So, we're going to skip that bone broth phase but the next phase is basically
just eating soups. You're not making bone broth out of the meat stock for the soup but you're just
eating soups. You're making yourself some chicken soup and you're eating soup. You're eating
soup is vegetables and meat products that are cooked. So, really, to excess, the carrots are very
soft. The celery is even soft. The meat has been cooked for all day long or multiple days if you
made a big pot of soup on Monday. It's now Thursday and you're still eating that pot of soup.
It's been cooked multiple days. So, it's very pre-digested. So, one of the issues if you have a lot
of issues with your gut, you have issues with digestion. Remember, the phases of your gut,
what your gut does, it has to break things down, that's digestion. And when you have hindrances
in digestion, that's why you would take digestive enzymes, that's why you take HCL products.
And then to help with that process, sometimes your gut wall is so damaged that if you're eating raw
foods that are not cooked, they're much more difficult digest. That's what this question is
leading to. Well, my greens, smoothies, those are freeze-dried vegetables. Yeah, they were partially cooked.
They have to be in order to be freeze-dried and then they're grown, but they're not fully cooked. So,
greens, smoothies, they would fall into the category of juiced food where they would fall into
the categories of at least partially raw food, which I would say eating a raw food diet is hard for
a lot of cancer patients, though, again, there's people out there that advocate for your gut cancer,
you should be eating a raw food diet, which I think is foolishness because most cancer patients
don't have gut issues, too, and it's very hard on your gut to eat a raw food diet. But
so, that's what this question is alluding to. Eating soups would be a good thing to do because
it's fully cooked. It's easier, it's softer on the gut. It's easier to digest. It's easier to absorb.
You're getting that nutrition without hindering and injuring the gut even further.
So, the question was, would it be better to omit the greens, smoothies, set them aside
for a period of time, and using things like soup as a choice instead, and then you're added to the
question. Not the powder, but real greens, vegetables, powders, a bit of fruit hooked into a soup
by all means absolutely. You can even, if you let's get greens first and you wanted to add it to
soup or something like that, I think it's got a mid-flavor, so probably not really good.
Maybe it would be good soup. But yes, if you had a greens drink, if you had the real greens that
you were grinding up, if you were juiced, you know, carrot juice, and then you added it to a soup,
and you cooked it all day in a soup. Yes, you're getting it cooked, you're breaking it down, so
that's the whole idea. You're basically using heat to break it down, breaking down some of the
fibers that make it easier to digest and easier to absorb. Absolutely. Yes, you could do all of that.
Similar to the question that we had last week or so, that was about, you know, can the capsules
themselves in my supplements? I think they're irritating my stomach. Can I open them up and just put
them in my smoothie? Yes, you know, by all means, that could be a good thing to do.
So, you don't want things that are going to irritate your gut. So, you're not going to get your
nutrition through any means if you have a really damaged gut. So, we want to be working out of healing
the gut.